hello there you wise and witty beautiful
human being i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report direct message it's
november 11 2021 as always you can chat
with other viewers at
rubinreport.locals.com we are now
streaming on rumble video we're
streaming on youtube streaming on blaze
tv and we are doing a reuben report
locals q a today we got a whole bunch of
questions submitted by you guys you
still have a chance there's a chance
because i do this for about a half hour
there's still a chance to get a question
in live while i'm doing this
reubenreport.local.com and of course you
can download the locals app on the apple
store at the apple store or you can
check us out on google play if you've
got an android and normally when i do
these q and a's we just throw to one
story up top but there were three things
that happened this morning so quickly
that i was like all right we've got to
touch on all of them so first off ron
desantis who is basically saving america
single-handedly uh has just had it with
old joe biden and he just had just an
awesome line yesterday that we're going
to throw to then speaking of joe biden
he referred to satchel paige one of the
uh baseball players in the old negro
league uh he referred to him as a negro
which uh you know that's not quite the n
word but joe is reading off these things
he's a little confused i'm fairly
certain if donald trump had said
exactly what joe biden said that
everybody would be demanding another
impeachment so we're going to show you
that and then and then this one's just
breaking you know this kyle rittenhouse
trial
which is really just sort of gone off
the rails here and it's such a perfect
example of how we're living in two
different realities because if you live
in i would say a reality that's roughly
close to the reality that i live in it's
fairly obvious uh that he's going to be
acquitted the prosecution has just done
an absolutely terrible job and
everything else but if you live in the
other reality he's guilty he's a white
supremacist you know america is a
patriarchy the system no matter what
happens it's proof that the system's
evil and everything else but there is
just an absolutely extraordinary moment
i mean this prosecutor is just
just incredibly terrible incredibly
terrible so we're going to show you some
video on that before we get to that and
then your questions i want to talk to
you guys about convention of states a
bunch of you have been asking me about
the convention of states and you know
there's no question in my mind obviously
that joe biden's vaccine mandates are
unconstitutional overreach if you're a
regular viewer or listener to this show
you probably agree with me the question
is what are we going to do about it we
can keep complaining we can keep voting
for quote unquote better federal
politicians but we've tried that and
guess what guys it's not working we need
a new better solution to federal
overreach and my friend mark meckler has
one article five of the constitution
allows the states to call
a convention of states this isn't about
politics this is about actual solutions
at this convention the states gather to
propose constitutional amendments that
take away everything career politicians
love their money their power their
careers in office and the best part
there's not a single thing the feds can
do to stop us this movement is supported
by names you know like glenn beck
governor ron desantis and mark levin go
to
conventionofstates.com dave today and
sign the petition to demand that your
state legislators vote yes
to convention of states i encourage you
to stop complaining and do something
that's what this whole show is all about
visit
conventionofstates.com dave and sign the
petition today again that's
conventionofstates.com
and now back to me okay first off
ron desantis has just had it with joe
biden and instead of just having it with
him and making fun of him and let's go
brandoning him he's actually got some
solutions to to figure out what to do
with old joe take a look if they're
going to come here you know we'll
provide buses and provide them
i will send them to delaware and do that
i mean if he's not going to support the
border being secured then then he should
be able to have uh everyone there
so we will do whatever we can in that
regard and we are absolutely going to do
everything we can
okay it's pretty perfect obviously what
he's referring to there is if we're not
going to defend the southern border and
then all of these people are going to
come through texas and then we know they
don't just stay in texas obviously in
many cases the federal government sends
them all over the nation but once
they're in the country they can
basically do whatever we want i thought
we were in some sort of pandemic and we
shouldn't have people wandering around
without mass and social distancing blah
blah blah forget all that but desantis
is basically like look if joe biden
won't do one of his very few jobs that
he's supposed to do biden does an awful
lot of stuff he's not supposed to do
mandates etc but one of the few jobs
that the federal government is supposed
to do is protect the borders if he won't
do it then we're not just going to let a
gajillion people who we know nothing
about we don't know about
their vaccine status we don't know about
their cultural sensitivities we don't
know about their political beliefs we
don't know if they're extremists
well we're not going to let them in
florida and you know what if they get
into florida we're just going to send
them to delaware that is the type of
response we need with these things it
really is and then it's like all right
delaware defend yourself from florida
from sending buses in it's like desantis
is doing
everything he can that man deserves
everyone's support right now it does not
matter if you agree with every political
position he has it's like he is freaking
trying and if i'm not mistaken i saw
yesterday
that the democratic party
in florida is basically they're not
going to not run a candidate i guess
this guy charlie crist who was once the
the governor of uh he was once the
governor if i'm not mistaken of florida
pretty sure he's closeted gay guy also
but you can google that if you want um
not that i care about him being gay but
if you're closeted it's a problem
because you could be blackmailed blah
blah blah
anyway they're basically pulling funds
out because they know that desantis is
pretty much unstoppable so pretty good
on the desantis front all right next up
this written house trial it's this
prosecutor is going to go down in the
history as one of the worst trial
lawyers of all time here just in the
last hour he was questioning a reporter
on the scene about what's go what was
going on there and listen to the way he
framed this question
um your
videos that you have captured of these
incidents that you call riots
they're
very
slanted against
the people who are rioting you
characterize them as antifa black lives
matter rioters correct because they are
rioting in the footage yes absolutely
you can't make this up the videos of the
riots are slanted against the rioters
and then the answer is pretty perfect
there i mean this guy is
absolutely terrible this is the same guy
who yesterday got smacked down by the
judge who basically was like you know
this is almost at the point of throwing
this whole case out because kyle
rittenhouse obviously has a right not to
incriminate himself he did take the
stand but like we're going to show you
videos of rioting and your videos are
actually slanted against the people
burning things down and attacking public
property and assaulting people and
everything else one more for you and
then we'll get to the questions well
here's joe biden today
you know i've adopted the
attitude of the great
negro at the time pitcher in the negro
leagues went on to become
a great pitcher in the pros into the
major league baseball after jackie
robinson his name was satchel page
the great negro at the time now i get it
joe biden was just misreading the
teleprompter and he doesn't really know
what he's saying and he's old and he's
confused and i don't think he meant that
in a racially pejorative way but just
for a moment imagine if donald trump
said that right we'd be in impeachment
seven there would be riots in the
streets
it would be abject insanity so poor joe
i mean they just keep putting them out
there he's breaking down in front of our
eyes and speaking of eyes his new thing
have you noticed this maybe we'll throw
to it one more time his new thing is he
can't open his eyes his eyes are like
this little thing let's throw to it one
more time you know i've adopted the
attitude of the great
negro at the time pitcher in the negro
leagues went on to become
a great pitcher in the pros into the
major league baseball after jackie
robinson
i'm not exactly sure what's going on
here maybe he adopted that great negro
league pitcher because he can't see
exactly what he's reading because you
know okay okay
all right let's get some questions uh
amy says what are your thoughts on the
creation of the university of austin is
this laying the groundwork to wake up
the woke universities or is it the
beginning of a big rift in our country
this is a great question uh so if you
haven't heard about this a bunch of
academics really almost everybody that's
involved in this has been in my studio
uh this is stephen pinker this is ayan
hershey ali this is my good buddy pete
bogosian this is
neil ferguson uh barry weiss is involved
this is a huge amount of what i would
say are the somewhat sane liberals i'm
not exactly sure if they consider
themselves liberals anymore this is
where the words sort of don't matter
that much i would say they're they're
they're the non-woke liberals something
like that um i would say really that
just makes you a conservative at this
point but let's not get too lost in that
in essence they are starting this
university uh it's called the university
of austin uh joe lonsdale is involved
joe alonso who is one of the co-founders
of palantir who was an investor in
locals like they've got good
freaking people involved in this thing
um my hope
is that they will actually be able to
fight some of the wokeness and and have
a university it's not an accredited
university i don't know that they're
giving out degrees i mean this is just
the beginning like you don't have all
the answers at once right and what do i
always say you have to build new things
right now we should be letting harvard
and yale let them all crumble under woke
social justice and build new things so i
think
basically this is a very good thing now
the question is when they are saying
that they're for you know viewpoint
diversity and everything else as far as
i know there's no one there that's
openly a trump supporter let's say i
think there's probably a couple people
who are closeted trump supporters uh but
i don't know of anyone that was openly a
trump supporter so where are you gonna
draw the lines if right now you're
starting this thing and you're saying
that sort of if you supported that guy
or or you're sort of in that half of the
country you're not part of this you're
not being represented on the faculty or
whatever uh heather heing is also going
to be part of this so anyway i'm i'm
hopeful for it but another piece of me
also thinks that like maybe we just
don't need these things anymore maybe we
really don't need universities anymore
if you're a 15 16 17 year old kid right
now and you're trying to figure out what
you want to do with your life and if you
can learn the amount that you can learn
because of
videos that you find online and now that
you can just connect to different people
because of social media everything else
like do you really need a four-year
university now i get it there are
technical professions like that you
really need to know something right and
you can go to technical schools for
those things or if you want to be an
engineer i'm not saying that there's no
value in having several years of
education i just think there's so many
new ways of doing things do we need
places with an actual campus
of course i get it also college is a
place where you it's not just about what
you learn sort of academically but also
you learn how to at least be a
some degree of an adult a young adult
going into the world so anyway i'm
hopeful for this i don't it doesn't have
all my hope but it has a bunch of my
hope i think that they'll need to widen
that net because they've mostly got
disaffected liberals and that's just
fine i know a little something about
that but you got to open it up to get
some of those scary conservatives and
maybe even beyond that get some
anarchists in there i don't know like
whatever it is if you're really going to
defend academic freedom you've really
got to do it so we shall see
antoinette says have you been following
the written house trial can we agree
that there is a systematic woke
prejudice in all of our institutions i
don't want to be cynical but at some
point we can't ignore the elephant in
the room so yeah i have been watching it
i haven't been sitting there all day
watching you know i'm seeing i'm seeing
the clips as they come out and i'm
trying to follow along as much as
possible uh tucker's been doing a really
nice job uh breaking some of it down
which is why we threw to one of his uh
videos yesterday um
we have a problem the woke thing has
infected everything so it's like when
i've been watching you know some of the
clips from msnbc people you know this
this muppet looking guy chris hayes or
uh joy reid or the rest of them when i
watch them or even some of the cnn
people the way they're analyzing it it's
like they still they're just saying over
and over that kyle ritenous is a white
supremacist he's not there's no evidence
he's a white supremacist and as i said
yesterday joe biden called kyle
rittenhouse a white supremacist like
we've all been through this game i think
one of the the things is if if you watch
a show like this and you've been
watching what i do for a while it's like
you've sort of seen the way the sausage
is made right like if you were with me
just at the beginning of september just
you know two three months ago when i was
campaigning with larry elder and to
watch the los angeles time calm the
black face of white supremacy and biden
call him a without saying his name a
trump clone a guy who was born in south
central son of a janitor like we start
seeing how the machine does things how
it how it lies about certain people and
how it elevates other people um and
that's what this trial sort of feels
like to me it's like if you basically
believe in the judicial system if you
believe that we can have an impartial
jury and a true honest fair trial well
it's happening in front of our eyes and
from from the way i see it right now the
prosecution has done an
atrocious truly atrocious job but you
can watch plenty of media and democrat
politicians right now who are basically
like lock them up and throw away the key
they're making jokes you know when he
started crying yesterday we showed you
that video
i saw a bunch of people making jokes
about oh how much more he's going to cry
when he's in the showers at the jail so
i guess gay rape jokes are okay for the
tolerant and diverse set so yeah this
this divide is just there we got to
figure out how to manage it uh celeste
says in your opinion what's the single
most important message that republicans
must trumpet during 2022 i think it's
simply this
do you like america or not period that's
it do you like america do you like the
flag do you like our founding do you
like our laws
if you like those things you're
basically on the conservative side of
things and you must vote out the
marxists and the left leftists that's
what happened in virginia right like we
don't want racism taught in the school
uh basic biology is real like the
republicans have such a simple message
and again i don't even consider myself a
republican like i'm certainly more of a
republican than i am a democrat but as i
always say you don't have to be a
republican you just can't be a democrat
right so the message is just so simple
let let them keep doing their thing
america's evil it's systemically racist
everyone's horrible and only if you give
us enough money and power and we you let
us have mandates over you and control
every part of your life
that's how we'll fix it that's one way
of looking at the world right that's the
the mainstream media left this worldview
and the republicans all they have to do
hey we can't solve all your problems but
we'll do the best we can to give you the
power back to solve your problems it's
basically here's the answer basically
they should be mapping desantis desantis
should be writing up a little script and
just handing it out to every republican
and that's it because basically
everything he's done in the last two
years has been pretty freaking spot on
and enough's enough and people are
looking people are looking for some
adults in the room right isn't everyone
kind of looking for that like when you
have these rare moments when you see
someone stand up for what they believe
in and say what they believe like how
important that is you know even uh the
the interview that i did with jordan
peterson from two days ago we showed you
the clip yesterday uh where he talked
about you know uh i this is jordan's
words basically i got the vaccine now
leave me the [ __ ] alone and jordan
doesn't drop the f-bombs that often and
it's like what he was expressing there
was
we did what you were supposed to do
we meaning whoever got the vaccine right
did what we were asked and they have not
given us any more freedom
and
i think in essence jordan i think
jordan's line actually was stupid me
meaning i thought that that's what they
were going to do now i never felt that i
never felt that if we did what they
wanted they would let us go it's not
theirs to give in the first place our
freedom right so like i never felt that
and i'm not surprised but i mention this
because uh jordan just standing up and
saying okay maybe i made a mistake or
silly me whatever it is but now we must
fight back we just need more people just
stand up say what you think see what
happens
uh kathy says how was your time in
florida last week we missed you i mean
it was spectacular it was just freaking
spectacular did you have a good time he
had a good time did you have a good time
he had a good time we had a great time
it was open the food was great the
people were happy
we bounced all over the miami area doing
all sorts of things that perhaps i'll
tell you more about in the next few
weeks but there's a lot of good energy
you know we moved locals down there so
we're hiring down there
my sister now lives in the area with her
kids like there's just there's just a
lot of good stuff happening there and
and as i said the other day it's like
here in la
i don't really go out but when i do
everyone's still wearing masks these
people it's just like it's like attack
of the clones it's just clones
everywhere still wearing masks there's
no discussion anywhere in the media
about or we can ever take masks off now
they want them through 2023 i mean it's
really psychosis but in florida there
was basically no one wearing masks and
if you wanted to wear masking war mask
and frankly i would look at people and
be like well that's unfortunate for you
but it's your choice and that's the way
it should be and the weather was great
and i didn't mind a little humidity and
my hair wasn't as flat as i thought it
was going to be it was all good it was
all good
tk says we were thinking about a trip to
texas in november 2022 but we'll have
will they have seceded by then
uh that's a good question i don't think
they will have seceded by then i don't
think things are quite at that point but
i do think as i said that there will be
a furthering separation of the blue and
red thing it will just sort of continue
to go and by the way texas is a little
closer on the fence than you might want
to believe you know texas has that blue
center of austin uh but you know ted
cruz only beat
uh beto o'rourke by what like two points
can we get the numbers on that the ted
cruz better over situation for senate
last time so it's not like texas at is
as solidly red as you would you might
want florida on the other hand is is
looking good in that department i don't
think texas will secede by the way i
don't want states to secede i don't want
there to be a civil war or any of those
things because as i always say they will
never let us alone if you if you took
all the red states and people just left
and then all the blue people in the red
states left the red states would
flourish the blue states would be
crumbling but they will not stop coming
for your success because your success
is what makes them angry in the first
place uh we got some numbers uh cruz in
the last election got
50.9 percent of the vote betto
got 48.3 so really think about that
that's basically a two and a half point
difference beto is a radical crazy furry
leftist he's a furry right he wears
furry costumes isn't that a whole thing
with him he's like a furry guys don't we
have that can we get that picture is
there a picture we can maybe throw up
what was the deal with him being a furry
or something but anyway the point is
he's he's an anti-gun big government
lefty he got 48.8 uh 48.3 of the vote
last time so you know that tells you
it's not as safe as perhaps it should be
why do i think beto o'rourke is a furry
there is something he is some sort of a
furry can we he what he was a cat he was
a cat okay i don't know exactly what
we're talking about here but just uh
you've got google uh peter says uh what
do you think happened to gavin newsom so
look gavin newsom disappeared for 11
days
after he got the booster shot
he came back i suppose it was yesterday
or the day before gave a press
conference said it was because his kids
wanted him to do halloween with him and
trick-or-treat with him and then he
canceled his trip to go to this climate
conference i don't believe any of that
now unfortunately we don't have
journalists we just don't have
journalists we have people who respond
to what politicians say so you know i
saw at this press conference a couple
journalists asked him like gavin where
were you and he says that and then they
just report that and that's it um there
are a bunch of people who are reporting
daily mail reported that insiders in his
circle said that he did have some sort
of physical reaction to the booster shot
that he had muscle weakness and
something going on with his face i don't
know if that's true but i know that if
ron desantis had disappeared for 11 days
media silent no video et cetera et
cetera people would be going completely
insane um and instead with newsom it's
like you disappear for 11 days no one
says a word then you give your excuse oh
you just wanted to hang out with your
kids for halloween while halloween was
10 days ago
but oh that's what you said so it must
be true i'm being told beto was a sheep
not a cat i don't know exactly what
we're talking about why do the furry
people love beto there's this group of
people that wear big furry costumes they
love better o'rourke so texas you've got
to watch out you see what i'm saying
anderton says uh what did you think
about elon musk challenging the un to be
transparent where the u.n food funding
goes do you think the u.s should be
giving money to them look the un is the
most deeply corrupt sort of globalist
nonsensical ridiculous organization that
could exist they had good intentions
when the when the u.n started you know
70-ish years ago right like after world
war ii they were trying to get this
league of nations type thing and
everybody would sort of work together
and make decisions that perhaps could
you know
get the world community in some sort of
cohesion and we could help people and
all sort of stuff it isn't they they
spend all day focused on the wrong
things if you look at the un's twitter
account it's tweeting about systemic
racism in the united states and gender
day and queer day and blah blah blah so
i would defund the whole thing actually
at this point the u.n they've become
pretty useless right you don't hear from
the u.n in this last two years with the
crazy worldwide pandemic didn't hear
much from the u.n that's partially
because trump defunded so much of it but
i would just basically i would kick him
out of new york city and just the united
states shouldn't be funding any of these
organizations anymore but for more on
the un and what it's like to work at the
un i did interview nikki haley who was
the american ambassador to the united
nations we did that right in the studio
and if you search reuben report nikki
haley it will show up danielle says hey
dave even though biden's poll numbers
are plummeting it's pretty clear that
the democrats do not care about the
polls they're not going to change their
positions but actually double down
harder do you think this will expose the
charade that that the democrats care
about the country will this wake up
their supporters
i took a sip for a little pause there
for that um one of the things that i've
seen over the last you know six years
let's say that i'm doing roughly this
show is that every time the left had a
chance to kind of look in the mirror
and say maybe we're going a little too
radical maybe we're shouting down too
many speakers maybe we're you know
de-platforming too many people maybe
we're attacking basic math and basic
science related to gender they just
project all that stuff on the other guys
and they just keep going i think there
are fundamental reasons for that i think
it's partly facts don't care about your
feelings it's that the left is so
wrapped up in their feelings that if
someone feels something even more so you
take the squad and the really radical
nutty leftists they really feel
something and they're crying and
screaming about it so then the good
liberals who don't really know what they
believe i think this is why i've come
around on some of the god stuff too they
don't really know what they believe
because they're all just sort of
secularists on steroids they see a bunch
of people screaming and crying so that
must mean that they're good then you see
sort of republicans or conservatives and
they're usually more put together and
thoughtful and calmer but somehow that
must mean that they're bad like they've
got power or something and they're
competent or you know that must have
something to do with the evil systemic
corruption or something like that so for
that reason the left always gets dragged
to its worst parts it's like where are
the good democrats now i know you can
point to tulsi gabbard i completely
agree i love her i adore her i think she
is a good woman and it would be it would
be nice if she could start a sort of
reset in the democratic party but i
honestly i don't even know if she
believes if she considers herself a
democrat anymore i'll gladly have her on
again to talk about it um but there is
no evidence that the the moderates in
the party have any chance now you could
take say kristin cinema
and uh who's the other guy um
who was the guy you know that wasn't
going um
uh joe manchin thank you um you could
take two of them and say all right well
they're sort of moderates they because
they stopped the bill from being passed
the 3.5 went to 1 trillion even though
money doesn't mean anything and whatever
so yeah it's not that there's nobody but
like is the energy and the future of the
party is it kristin cinema and joe
manchin like i don't think so they've
decided to go in with this thing and
that that's why social justice was such
a danger this entire time because it was
a cult not a political ideology if you
tell me there's a political ideology
what do we believe like what do i
believe i believe in individual rights i
believe that the government shouldn't do
that much but i'm not an anarchist so it
should you know control borders there
should be police and firefighters things
of that nature and we then we can talk
about taxes and by the way if you're
interested in any more of my specific
thoughts on any of this it's all laid
out and don't burn this book
i would prefer a flat tax blah blah blah
like i have some sense of what i believe
individual rights and and your dignity
as a human being to live for yourself is
is sort of tantamount to western society
leftists basically believe if they could
just have enough power to do the stuff
they want that that in and of itself is
good enough so they're always going to
that
those two positions they don't really
work and that's why that's why what's
happening right now feels so crazy
because this isn't just liberals and
conservatives arguing with each other i
want higher taxes for more government
programs i want lower taxes for less
government programs okay there's a
there's a debate and then we can sit in
a room and go okay you're going to kind
of win a little bit on this you're going
to win a little bit on this we're both
going to lose nobody's going to be
totally happy and that's what a good
negotiation is that's not what we have
anymore we have people who want to
destroy the project and then we have
people who want to save the project and
that doesn't mean that every republican
is great obviously because they ain't uh
but that's where we are so i don't sense
that they're gonna turn around uh but
and really to your point like so biden's
numbers are really going down right now
i think it's his approval's at like 38.
kamala's at like 28 as jimmy kimmel said
that's because we're all racist and
sexist but they will not stop because
they believe in ideology more than truth
and and to some degree if you want the
silver lining on that the silver lining
is they're destroying an awful lot of
stuff we know prices are going up and
gas and all the stuff right we know it's
all happening they're telling us that
thanksgiving's gonna be more expensive
and get less presents for christmas and
blah blah and it's like well enough
people are waking up to that and going
man these guys suck this guy's worse
than jimmy carter so i do sense a red
wave and then then we'll see where we're
at
sandra says is it impossible to break
our made in china addiction i feel like
we're past the point of no return but
how could we turn that into an advantage
i think trump would have found a way we
are so locked in with china because of
debt that we have and poor trade deals
and this is all the stuff that trump was
screaming about for five years basically
you know from the year before he was
president four years he was president
everyone would call him racist because
of it he tried to stop travel from china
at the beginning of kovid he was told he
was racist
he called it the china virus that was
racist too but we have a huge problem
with china on our hands china is
stealing rip china is putting fentanyl
on our streets china most likely
had something to do with a lab leak that
put covet here in the first place um we
are becoming more china-like every day i
referenced this the other day but in my
interview with blake masters who's
running for senate in arizona a couple
weeks ago he talked about how as we
started sitting down with china the
original idea of the last say 10 15
maybe even 20 years was that china would
become more like us they would see a
liberal democracy and they would say oh
we want to be more like you we want more
people to be free we want more people to
have opportunity things like that but
unfortunately we've become more like
china we now have mandates we don't
respect individual rights we're forcing
companies to do things that they don't
want so
we're not in a good place with china i
got a little update here trump signed
multiple orders to support american made
goods and started a buy american
movement which of course was told was
called racist now biden says something
similar to that he's not racist when he
does it he calls it bill back better or
something trump called it buy america um
so you you see this stuff here i don't
know how we get out of the situation
with china but it really is the issue
like if you think russia is our biggest
uh geopolitical foe it's like no that's
that's not it it really this right now
is all about china and do we have enough
people it sort of goes back to one of
the first questions do we have enough
people who will stand up and say no i'm
i'm here for america
i believe in america and i don't want to
be subordinate to china and we're not
just going to let them ever encroach on
us and change the way we live and and be
their [ __ ] basically because that's
what we're becoming uh perry says pride
is a powerful thing i suspect that's one
of the reasons the left can't get over
trump what could persuade them to get
beyond their pride and vote differently
look this is this is the great challenge
right like what one of the things that
the left does really well is they hate
whenever a conservative is in power and
they they took that to like the zenith
right the apex of that with trump where
they made him into you know orange
hitler but they take anyone that's in
power that's republican it's always the
most awful thing possible but then when
they're out of power they kind of like
them again now they haven't done this
with trump but you know they do kind of
like george w bush now right they they
like uh the idea
they love liz cheney now because she's
sort of on her out on the outs with the
republicans so now she's a good
republican um so how do we get them to
put their pride away well this is what
you're really asking i think is what
does the future of the republican party
look like if it's going to be sort of
wider
right so like look i think you can make
an absolutely good argument for why
trump should run again i think he still
is the energy of the party he's still
sort of the center of the universe if
you want to talk about rallies and blah
blah blah and all of that stuff it's
like it makes a lot of sense
on the other hand you know that a
certain amount of people no matter what
they have their reasons it is what it is
they don't like the personality they
can't get over it they've been confused
by the media all of the whatever
they're just not going to go in that
direction okay it just is so what makes
more sense to me would be that you would
take a guy like desantis who i think is
making all the right choices have trump
acting as the bodyguard i've talked
about this before deal with the media
nonsense get the rallies going and like
sort of step aside do the one thing that
trump's never really done which is put
the ego aside a little bit for i don't i
don't like the phrase the greater good
but for for the for the chance that
america can can get through this crazy
marxist insanity that would be the best
move i think because i don't think a lot
of the people that are truly deranged by
trump they're not going to come around
and by the way you know if if trump in
his heart of hearts
if he actually believes that the
election was fixed now i'm probably
going to get booted for talking about
what someone else thinks about something
but if trump really believes that they
fixed the election and they colluded and
whatever it is that he believes at this
point or he talks about well then why
wouldn't they just do it again has he
done anything
uh and i say this is someone that voted
for trump and probably would vote for
him again if he ran although i would
gladly vote for desantis first i think
you see my point um if if he believes
that they really did fix it last time
well then has he done anything or has he
overseen anything that would stop them
from doing it again
that's not a reason not to run but like
you got to think about that a little bit
don't you don't you have to be like oh
we really needed to get more people on
the ground in these places and
everything else now by the way the
republicans have been trying to do some
things on the ground related to
elections like in texas and in georgia
et cetera et cetera and they're called
racists for it and everything else
because you know if you show your id to
show to vote you're a racist if you show
your iv id to get out of play in that
same but you know you get it so anyway
this is what the republicans have to
figure out is what does this collection
of people look like there's a lot of
interesting people right you've got dan
crenshaw you've got nikki haley you've
got tim scott you've got trump you've
got desantis like there is a collection
of something and could everyone sort of
get in a room and be like hey we got a
much bigger problem we got a much bigger
problem than whatever our differences
are like the
the ominous move of communism marxism
it's here so let's figure out the best
way to do this i think if trump can make
that move
like what a cool sort of uh ending to
the story doesn't even have to fully be
the end but like what a cool sort of
chapter of the story where he was like
you know what there's someone else that
might be a little more effective as an
administrator here that wouldn't cause
all of the lunacy and i can help and i'm
going to help instead of making it all
about me like that actually seems kind
of cool to me
marissa says do you see any way the
written house verdict doesn't end in
riots
probably not um i think there's gonna be
riots look well i do think he's gonna be
acquitted if anything i have watched
has been indicative of what's gonna
happen i mean this prosecution's been
absolutely horrible so
i do think he will be acquitted i mean
the prosecutor was talking about how he
plays video games so he wants to kill
people i mean really just like bat [ __ ]
loony stuff
um the left has learned that if you
don't get your way you can riot right
even now i just saw this morning that in
new york city where the new mayor eric
adams he's the new incoming mayor uh
he's saying that he may start funding
police again and start may may start
cracking down on some of the crime etc
etc well now blm and antifa are saying
that they are going to bring back riots
if he does that so it's like how are
they not designated as domestic
terrorist organizations we have a
certain subset in society that says if
you don't do what we want we will bring
violence and it's interesting because
you know in the last 10 months since
biden became president where have all
the riots been did we stop systemic
racism have no people been shot by
police or could it be that they're sort
of coordinated guys hear me out i'm
going on one of my crazy theories
that perhaps all the riots
and the destruction and blm and antifa
are actually somehow connected loosely
to the democrats and when they need more
violence they can kind of turn it on and
when they want less they can kind of
close the spigot could that possibly be
or am i a complete conspiracy theory
maniac i'll have to think about that
tallway says with the federal government
looking at shutting down michigan's line
five something governor gretchen whitmer
has been looking at for years and with
the keystone project shut down what do
you see happening as winter comes on and
common people need more energy you know
this is a little bit related to my
conversation with jordan peterson the
other day about the best way to make
human flourishing to free people and for
economic
success and to get people less reliant
on the system is cheap energy cheap
energy that is what will do it and then
we can deal with climate issues and as
jordan talked about he'd like to get a
summit going to really debate climate
issues honestly as opposed to oh you
have to believe in global warming the
way they lay it out and you have to
believe in all of their remedies
otherwise you know you're you're a
conspiracy theorist and everything else
um
look we know gas prices are rising we
know about all the supply chain stuff i
sense it's it's going to be pretty bad
probably in certain parts of the country
in the in the more northern and eastern
states as it gets colder uh
if gas prices are going up and heating
prices are going up and oil prices are
going up and everything else it's like
that's not good for common people that's
not good for the average person you know
when when gas prices rise biden says
well i'm never going to tax you know
poor people we're just going to tax
those rich people well if you if gas
prices keep rising who who does that
affect does that affect the rich guy in
his tesla or does it affect the the poor
person who has to drive further to work
or has to drive the truck etc etc so i
sense it's it's going to be a kind of
rough winter and then of course you know
they'll they'll be pushing more coveted
stuff and it's back and dark winter and
everyone's dying and blah blah blah it's
like man
get some control over your life know
what you believe figure out how to be
less reliant on these people and you you
will be happier this is this is very
much what my next book is about uh all
right last question landon says do you
feel that the conservative movement is
actually gaining ground or are we just
thinking that these small victories are
just stop gaps holding back the
inevitable flood of leftism i like that
we're ending on this one look i think at
some level
this the the the specter
of marxism and leftism it's sort of here
like they've infected so many young
people they've infected so many systems
teachers
brainwashing kids into believing they're
not the gender that they are
telling them that two plus two doesn't
equal for all of the stuff it is so
rotted and it is so in it is so
uh institutionalized in everything that
we all see right it's it's on apple tv
or you have it's on netflix like it's
it's coming through the pipes and the
programming and all of those things and
that all feels horrible and it sucks but
you know i often talk about that that
star in the distance and how we need
hope right
and we got hope at a political level a
week and a half ago basically with the
election in virginia parents stood up
and stopped terry mcauliffe who i don't
think he stands for anything but so he
in essence was standing for crazy woke
leftism and teaching critical race
theory and everything else and parents
stood up and glenn younkin won now
that's a win that's a real
win and then it makes more people
probably in other states go boy you know
something did happen we showed up to
vote we pushed back and we got a win so
it's going to happen on a state-by-state
basis it's going to happen on a local
basis i also think culturally
you know it's kind of it's kind of
coming around a bit right before we
started the show uh michael said to me
that uh ben shapiro was on joe rogan
yesterday
and uh what was the line roughly he said
rogan said something to the effect of
ben to ben at the beginning something
like oh aren't you happy that it's it's
cool to be a republican is that you said
something like that that more people are
becoming republican right now and it's
like all right
maybe
the the more painful
long slog that a bunch of us have been
through fighting the machine being
called the leader of the far right like
the new york times called me
or just all the stuff that we've all
sort of been through
that you guys have seen it's like maybe
we are winning converts average decent
people right like i i know somebody i
don't want to give to too much away but
somebody that i know here in la who's in
the entertainment business that it was
really like a
banana's lefty his whole life like far
more left than i even ever was
who is completely red pilled right now
because he works in entertainment and no
longer can hire teams of writers based
on their skill their writing skill and
he happens to be in comedy i've said too
much at this point uh but he can't hire
a writer's room filled with the funniest
people he has to get oh i have one
indian i have one trans woman i have one
[ __ ] i have somebody who's deaf
somebody who's blind i mean it's a
comedy in and of itself right but now
he's red pill they're red pilling the
average person so i i am hopeful in that
regard this is you know a little bit of
what michael malus would talk about is
you want these people to be out there as
much as possible saying all of their
crazy [ __ ] so for every person that it
feels like aoc says these crazy things
and and then for a certain amount of
young people that are like oh my god
she's so right she's on tick-tock and
she's drunk and she's laying on the
floor while she's talking she's so right
and she loves bernie well then the
question is how many people do actually
look at that and be like man
she doesn't know what she's talking
about she's completely ridiculous these
people are still wearing masks they
still believe that the government's
gonna save you from all of those things
so i think there has been a mass red
pill and we just need to keep showing up
we keep
just it's what i always say just talk
just tell your neighbors and your family
what you think it ain't easy we've all
got problems i guarantee you every
single person watching this right now
and myself included and the guys in this
room and everybody else we've all got
issues saying what you think everybody's
got it right family problems right now
everyone i know oh i think everyone i
know is dealing with some other family
problem related to politics or belief or
mandates or everything else
the choice is you will either stand up
and say what you believe or you'll just
oh okay vaccinate my kids okay do it do
what's against my conscience okay i'll
wear a mask forever okay fine fine fine
like do you think that the world will
suddenly magically get better it won't
and and that's exactly what i was
talking about with jordan peterson i
think he was he was having a really sort
of beautiful maya culpa and it came with
a little bit of a little bit of pain and
anger which is why he dropped the f-bomb
when he said it he's he's saying man i
thought if i did this you guys would let
up but this ideology does not want to
let up and by the way i would grant
jordan a very long leash on this because
he had such horrific health stuff for a
year and a half
that maybe he made a decision without
fully
thinking it all completely through i
don't want to put words in his mouth and
i'll gladly discuss it with him again
but like people are waking up i've seen
the reaction to the video and an awful
lot of people were like yeah i kind of
did it too i got the vaccine because i
thought they'd let us out again and
meanwhile here in los angeles right now
unless you are vaccinated you cannot go
to a restaurant you cannot go to a bar
for now they'll let you go to the
supermarket but like they're not going
to stop they're not going to stop so
what did you do at the time
when it was here and it was on the front
at the front door
did you hold the door did you get your
house in order or as douglas murray said
did you just debate which gender
pronouns they are as they're you know
rampaging through the castle the choice
is yours part two of my interview with
jordan peterson is up right now on the
youtube the full is up already ad free
at
reubenreport.locals.com and tomorrow we
are back with a friday panel we've got
stu bergery from the blaze lauren chen
and allison williams from the daily wire
she's the one who was on espn and then
did not want to go along with their
vaccine mandates so she left uh espn and
she joined the daily wire that's what
i'm talking about standing up for what
you believe in and you will find success
on the other side i just know it my life
is a is an example of it and there's so
many other examples as well anyway hope
you enjoyed the show today have a great
day and we'll see you tomorrow